[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec à
mes côtés thibault et not bon gentil
bonjour oriane est notre invité cette
semaine et vincent capo-canellas ce
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur union
centriste de la seine saint denis
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous et dans
l'actualité cette semaine il ya d'abord
cette question l'exécutif et il tirait
d'affaires dans la crise des gilet jaune
le gouvernement en tout cas résister
sans difficulté à un vote de défiance
jeudi à l'assemblée
trois jours après les annonces du
président de la république sans rod plus
haut niveau du smic c'est l'une des
mesures clés justement annoncé par
emmanuel macron elle passe par une
hausse de la prime d'activité elle a été
votée sans attendre au sénat mardi
les autres mesures promises devraient
être adoptées d'ici à la fin de l'année
ce qui rend le calendrier législatif
compliqué enfin le terrorisme à nouveau
au coeur de l'actualité le gouvernement
a dû répondre aux interrogations de
l'opposition après l'attentât de
strasbourg l'arsenal législatif est il
suffisant il va en tout cas bientôt être
renforcé avec la création du parquet
national anti terroriste prévu par la
loi justice loi adoptée mardi à
l'assemblée et on commence avec les
répercussions politiques de la crise des
gilets jaunes le gouvernement philippin
a fait face et une motion de censure
jeudi à l'assemblée
[Musique]
trois jours après les annonces des
manuels macron l'exécutif a défendu sa
réponse à la crise dès gilet jaune
devant l'assemblée nationale
il a fait le service après-vente des
mesures sur le pouvoir d'achat
censée répondre à la crise mais pour
l'opposition de gauche
à l'origine de cette motion de censure
il n'y a aucun changement de cap
elle continue à défendre plus de justice
fiscale et le retour de l' isf
maïté frémont la motion de censure n'est
pas adopté l'issue ne laissait pas
vraiment de place au suspense
après trois heures de débat la motion de
censure de la gauche
voté par seulement 70 députés et balayé
par l'assemblée nationale
mais cela n'aura tout de même pas
empêché des échanges tendus sur les
bancs de l'hémicycle
bien loin d'être rempli l'un des temps
forts c'est cette prise de parole du
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste à
la tribune olivier faur accusent le
gouvernement de cynisme
la raison son groupe avait demandé un
report de l'examen de la motion
après les événements de strasbourg vous
avez fait le choix cynique d'utiliser le
drame pour mieux cacher la crise une
déclaration qui provoquent le départ des
députés de la république en marche et la
colère du président de l'assemblée
monsieur garraud qui représentait qui
représentez votre groupe
à aucun moment il a demandé le report de
ce débat alors s'il vous plaît ne
manquez pas le cynisme car le cynique
aujourd'hui chacun l'aura reconnu ici de
son côté andré chassaigne premiers
signataires liste un certain nombre de
revendications de son groupe
l'augmentation du smic des salaires des
pensions des prestations sociales
vous allez nous dire que ces mesures
aggraver l'état de nos finances
publiques
pas du tout pour cela il suffit de
rétablir lisf lisf une obsession de la
gauche pour gilles legendre patron du
groupe majoritaire
vous sautez sur votre banc tel le cabri
chère au général de gaulle en criant isf
isf isf il doit philippe lui n'a pas
manqué d'épingler cette alliance des
gauches
je serais curieux
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
connaître le programme qui vous serez
commun si j'ose dire
prochaine étape la semaine prochaine
avec l'examen du projet de loi qui
reprendra l'essentiel des mesures
annoncées par emmanuel macron vincent
capo-canellas sont à vue en ce débat
dans le débat fallait-il reporter cette
motion de censure suite à l'attentât de
strasbourg est ce que pour vous faire
cette motion de censure jeudi c'était
opportun est sûr que ce débat n'est pas
forcément arriver au au meilleur moment
et que les français sont conscients d'un
certain nombre de difficultés qui sont
de notre nature je crois que aujourd'hui
quand on voit la situation du pays
on a eu l'attentât de strasbourg
on voit les déclarations du président à
public on voit que le mouvement des
gilet jaune est toujours présent qui a
les difficultés de pouvoir d'achat il
faut se concentrer maintenant sur les
solutions et essayer de faire qu'on
sorte de cette crise perpétuelle on
danse aujourd'hui sur un volcan
avec nos compatriotes qui sont révoltés
par un certain nombre d'inégalités et
qui sont à temps à la tente que les
politiques fournissent des solutions et
je vous souhaiterez mois que le débat
politique maintenant se concentre sur
les vrais sujets sains et qu'on arrête
un peu les joutes parlementaires qu'on
sache s'ils se dire que nous avons un
devoir collectif qui est de répondre
dans le cas des institutions montré que
le parlement peut faire oeuvre utile et
pas forcément se caricaturer nous mêmes
alors sur le fond si vous étiez député
est ce que vous auriez et voter cette
motion de censure n'auraient pas voté la
motion de censure je pense que c'est pas
la peine d'ajouter du débat
parlementaire supplémentaires un moment
où le débat est dans la rue et où chacun
vit une situation qui était proche de
l'insurrection
au contraire je pense que les
institutions ont un devoir de
responsabilité c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de faire au sénat en étant aussi aller
coûte de certaines propositions du
gouvernement on l'a fait jusqu'au moment
du vote de la première lecture du projet
de loi de finances et nous avons le
devoir aujourd'hui d'une forme de
sobriété et de recherche d'efficacité
c'est ça qui est attendu en notre
direction et donc je vais pas voter
cette motion parce qu'en plus elle est
contradictoire
on voit bien qu'il ya une alliance du
moment de qui permet simplement à chacun
d'essayer d'exister
le sujet n'est pas là l'insuffler tic
pour vous ça pour la gauche est bien
évidemment la gauche essaye d'exister
essaye de surfer sur la sphère des
jeunes qui ne demandent pas d'ailleurs
de récupération
je pense que c'était un faux débat et
que la page est assez rapidement tourné
alors sur le fond à la gauche demandent
le retour de liesse f le sénat on a
débattu il a rejeté est ce que vous
comprenez l'importance symbolique de
cette mesure pour les français au moment
où leur demande des efforts je crois
surtout que le gouvernement était
extrêmement maladroit dans sa politique
fiscale
tout ça est totalement qui lisible entre
la taxe d'habitation qui finalement sera
supprimé pour certains mais pas pour
tout le monde
en plusieurs fois on voit bien que les
mesures annoncées sur les baisse des
cotisations sociales pour les salariés
ont finalement eu lieu pour une part
enfin au dernier trimestre auront lieu
plus tard tout ceci c'est une forme de
galimatias que personne ne comprend la
politique fiscale est illisible
elle a donné un sentiment d'injustice
ailier s'est fait devenu un symbole je
pense qu'il aurait fallu l'aménager
plutôt que je suis privé mais nous
devons aujourd'hui quand même avoir
aussi un cap
le cap c'est de permettre à la france
quand même dans les standards
internationaux de ne pas être montrés du
doigt et chacun voit bien que les sf
était devenue un point de focalisation
donc je pense gouvernement s'y est très
mal pris et qu' il n'a pas mesuré que sa
politique était devenue illisible et
qu'elle donne le sentiment d'être
injuste ça c'est une réalité qu'il faut
maintenant prendre en compte mais je
suis au lit sf en lui-même
c'était un impôt dont on a tous rappelé
qu'il avait beaucoup d faut d'abord
celui de faire que incertum
d'investissement n'avait plus eu en
france un syndrome de nos compatriotes
qui en avaient les moyens des ménages et
le problème c'est me semble ni surtout
la fiscalité des classes moyennes est un
sentiment de déclassement de tous ceux
qui travaillent qui payent des impôts et
qui ont le sentiment qu'ils travaillent
beaucoup et que finalement ils sont sûrs
fiscalisés c'est ça me semble utile de
vrai sujet c'est sûr ça qu'il faut qu'on
travaille donc lisf honoré du traité
différemment
il ya quand même l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière voilà donc y ait un certain
de taxation des hauts revenus
ça peut se discuter je pense peut être
que dans le barème de l'ir d'imposition
il y aura quelque chose à faire c'est ça
plutôt la solution sur le plan politique
après les annonces du président le rejet
de cette motion de censure est ce que
vous dites que le gouvernement est tiré
d'affaires d'après vous
je pense que le gouvernement n'est pas
au bout de ses peines et que la colère
des français est une réalité
le gouvernement a enchaîné un certain
nombre de maladresses vis-à-vis de
l'opinion commises à vis du parlement
commises à vis de l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires la france pour être
réformé ça suppose qu'il y ait quand
même une discussion qui est le temps du
débat qui est une appropriation des
mesures du gouvernement est là pour
fixer un cap le président a été élu il a
donné un cap
pourquoi pas sur un certain nombre
d'orientations mais tout est aussi dans
la précision des mesures tout est aussi
dans la concertation tout est aussi dans
la mise en oeuvre et que le gouvernement
n'ait pas vu au moment de l'annoncé des
grandes mesures du projet de la finance
la fameuse interview du premier ministre
au journal du dimanche qui a annoncé des
mesures un petit peu sèche notamment la
désindexation des retraites
la désindexation des allocations
familiales par exemple
et puis cette montée de la fiscalité
verte que le gouvernement n'ait pas vu
qu'à un moment donné ça allait rentrer
l'incompréhension et la colère des
français
c'est un sujet chacun pouvait mesurer
fin août que la question du pouvoir
d'achat
venez très fortement et un sorte de
l'indicateur dé montrer aussi que les
classes moyennes
en tout cas ceux qui sont au début des
classes moyennes entre guillemets dans
l'échelle des revenus rencontrer de
vraies difficultés
cette colère là n'a pas été vu donc un
problème de capteur et apprennent de
remontée d'informations et apprennent de
concertation la france a besoin de
réformes et un certain d'orientation
nous pouvons les partager mais ça doit
se faire dans la concertation dans le
dialogue et je crois qu'à des signaux
qui sont parés du dialogue de la
majorité on l'a vu a sans surprise a
réaffirmé son soutien au gouvernement et
les parlementaires ont été reçus à
l'elysée mardi les parlementaires de la
majorité
par emmanuel macron le président
souhaite visiblement aussi changer de
méthode être plus à l écoute des élus il
faut dire que sa réponse était attendue
par des députés de la majorité parfois
déboussolée ces dernières semaines ils
ont apparemment été à rassurer de leur
rencontre avec le président écoute et je
pense qu'il a fendu l'armure je pense
que j'ai on a vu franchement emmanuel
macron qui s'est peut être dit sean un
peu vite et j'aurais dû faire autrement
moi je retrouve un emmanuel macron de
campagne était venu de ma
circonscription et je crois qu'il a
compris qu'il fallait continuer à faire
des réformes structurelles mais une
majorité politique pas faire à saintes
une majorité social l'erreur collectif
qui a été fait c'est
d'accélérer ou de faire très fort la
réforme sur le monde économique sur
l'attractivité sur la reconstruction
construction des forces productives et
du coup de fait de donner l'impression
de délaisser les classes moyennes et
populaires l'action sur le social et ça
je pense que c'est on peut assez
facilement se convaincre que c'est aussi
une des raisons de la crise qu'on a
qu'on a connu et donc on doit corriger
et nous sommes une majorité aujourd'hui
qui est beaucoup plus beaucoup mieux
s'armer parce qu'elle a 18 mois derrière
elle parce qu'elle avait plongé quelques
quelques crises et parce qu'elle a envie
de continuer continuer à réformer le
pays avec des réformes qui sont
importantes qu'on a eu on a eu un
président qui est qui a pris ce qui a
pris la mesure qui est très pédagogue
qui qui est dans la concertation qui est
ouvert ouvert aux remontées de terrain
et qui est tout simplement ouvert à tous
et si je pense qu'il a tiré parti de
deux expériences et que en amas
intelligent et fin politique qui prendra
conscience de des bonnes réponses à
apporter davantage vous écoute et à
l'avenir je pense et ce qu'il a eu un
mot également pour les députés qui ont
été agressés il a commencé par ça c'est
sa première intervention et les a
réconfortés en leur disant qu on était
une famille qu'on pouvait compter sur
sur nous tous sur notre solidarité et
mais surtout il leur a dit qu'il fallait
être solide fort et faire face à ces
menaces qui allait se reproduire
nécessairement est ce que cette crise va
marquer un tournant dans la relation
entre emmanuel macron et les élus entre
emmanuel macron et le parlement pour
moment on a entendu du président de la
république une meilleure prise en compte
des mères en tout cas l'assurance que ce
point-là été a été pris en compte chez
lui dont acte
et pourquoi pas je crois que le dialogue
avec le parlement c'est surtout le
prémisse qui veulent mener le
gouvernement et de ce point de vue là il
ya encore beaucoup d'efforts qu'il faut
accomplir
on voit bien dans la navette
parlementaire avait dans les discussions
préalables que tout ça manque de
souplesse et que finalement on nous dit
le gouvernement a forcément raison
il n'y a pas de place au travail
parlementaire c'est très bizarre c'est
très paradoxal avait présidé à l'époque
la commission spéciale du sénat sur la
loi macron et le présent de la
république qui était alors ministre de
l'économie était l écoute du parlement
il ya eu 1
les débats nous sortons du débat
budgétaire au sénat c'est peu dire qu'il
ya eu c'est beaucoup dire qu'il ya eu un
vrai débat et on a des ministres qui
viennent qui souvent lise défi choix
donc démocratie parlementaire ça c'est
incarne et ça suppose que on met les
choses sur la table et qu'on sorte d'une
vision techno trop techno dans les
discussions avec le parlement alors
voilà il faut réhabiliter le vrai débat
politique
vous parliez de ce débat au sénat on va
y venir justement puisque au lendemain
des annonces des manuels macron le sénat
votait le budget 2010 9
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un vote solennel qui était prévu dans le
calendrier parlementaire mais qui vient
se télescoper avec les annonces du
président de la république emmanuel
macron a suivi le vote du sénat sur la
suppression de la hausse de la taxe sur
les carburants le sénat lui a intégré
les mesures de l'exécutif sur la prime
d'activité marie brémaud ce sont bien
les mesures annoncées par emmanuel
macron qui ont agité l'hémicycle au
sénat dans la dernière ligne droite de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
2010 9 plus d'une centaine d'heures
d'examen et de débats au palais du
luxembourg
quelque peu remise en cause par les
nouvelles mesures fiscales et sociales
du président le gouvernement revient
aujourd'hui devant nous pour la
troisième fois en trois semaines avec
des propositions de modification en
profondeur de son projet de budget 2010
dont acte compte tenu de la situation
sociale de notre pays
nous voterons d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre une grande partie des nouvelles
mesures
nous pensons que si ces mesures coûtent
très cher on devra les financer
évidemment et que nous ne pouvons pas
les financer par toujours plus de
dépenses publiques par toujours plus de
dettes
rappel au règlement des présidents de
groupe et au final une adoption large du
projet de loi de finances avec comme le
souhaitait l'exécutif une hausse de la
prime d'activité budgétisé par le
ministre a à 600 millions d'euros
mais aussi la suppression de la hausse
des taxes sur le carburant
une mesure votée par le sénat avant
d'être reprise par le gouvernement ce
que n'a pas manqué de souligner le
président du groupe socialiste fait d
organisation des travaux budgétaires
aurait pu être évité si le gouvernement
avait tenu compte plutôt des
propositions exprimées ici ou ailleurs
par les différents groupes
parlementaires qui composent la
haute-assemblée projet de loi largement
modifié par le sénat qui n'a pas su
trouver un accord avec l'assemblée
nationale lors de la commission mixte
paritaire le texte revient donc devant
les deux assemblées dès la semaine
prochaine
alors vincent capo-canellas ce
annulation la hausse de la taxe sur les
carburants défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires recul sur la csg des
petits retraités tous ces points étaient
défendues par l'opposition centriste et
la droite c'est une victoire politique
pour vous ça montre que le sénat peut
fournir des solutions
j'avais écrit une tribune ya à peu près
un an et demi dans le monde pour dire
que les mâles et macron devait écouter
le sénat et que justement la france des
territoires la france et l'ue est une
institution qui n'est pas politiquement
aligner pouvait aider justement à
accrocher sa politique au réel et donc
on l'a montré la la saynète l écoute on
a accepté in extremis d'intégrer deux
amendements gouvernementaux a souvent de
deuxième délibération ça n'est pas rien
ça n'était pas tu pas une obligation
pour nous donc voilà on ne peut apporter
des solutions de manière constructive
alors la mesure la plus sûre phares
annoncées par emmanuel macron lundi soir
c'est le fait que les personnes au smic
verront désormais leur salaire augmenter
de 100 euros des questions se posent sur
le détail de cette mesure sur son
financement est ce que pour vous c'est
flou le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que c'est flou c'est de l'improvisation
et est toujours là on attend cros et des
ministres mercredi prochain on attend un
projet de loi on en connaît assez peu la
consistance je souhaite que le parlement
est quand même le temps de travailler à
le temps d'interroger les ministres
aient le temps de l'expertisé tout ça
parce que ce sont des mesures concrètes
pour les français jusque là on voit que
la traduction du discours présidentiel
n'a pas forcément été anticipée par le
gouvernement
alors les questions se posent à 1 ghz et
sur le financement de ces mesures
comment les financer le gouvernement les
chiffres à 10 milliards mais comment les
financer sans laisser filer les déficits
et rodez passé à la fameuse barre des 3%
c'est la difficile équation pour le
gouvernement d'autant que bruxelles
veille bruno le maire et pierre
moscovici étaient tous deux auditionné
au sénat cette semaine
adrien de velet et sarah bencherifa les
annonces des manuels macron ont été
chiffré à 10 milliards d'euros le
déficit de la france devrait donc
dépasser les 3% du pib pour atteindre
3,4 pour cent en 2019 enfin
à ce dépassement la commission
européenne se veut conciliante
bon le souhait de la commission et le
partage lascaux dit denise et financer
que ce déplacement soit le plus limité
possible car c'est l'intérêt de la
france car cela évite de faire croître
davantage le fardeau de la dette
nous attendons ses mesures de
financement en souhaitant en effet que
français continue à travailler comme il
le fait à la fois sur le volet recettes
et sur le volet dépenses
un moment de répit pour bercy dans la
lutte contre le déficit
la commission européenne tolère un
dépassement pouvant atteindre jusqu'à 3
5% du pib sur un an
mercredi face aux sénateurs bruno le
maire a rappelé sa volonté de maîtriser
les comptes publics
je considère qu'il n'y a pas de
croissance économique solide et durable
sans un rétablissement des finances
publiques
nous ferons tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour rester le plus près possible des 3%
de déficit public en 2010 9
pour cela plusieurs pistes sont
envisagées la baisse des dépenses de
l'état
l'augmentation de l'effort demandé aux
entreprises et la taxation des géants du
web
les fameux google amazon facebook et
apple
taxer les gaffes à interviendrait dans
le projet de loi pâte pour autant seuls
une harmonisation au niveau européen
serait efficiente pour le moment paris
peine encore à obtenir l'accord des
autres pays européens
vincent capo-canellas ce gouvernement
chiffre l'ensemble des mesures annoncées
par emmanuel macron à 10 milliards est
ce que pour vous c'est le bon chiffre a
joué les sous-estimer on est encore un
peu dans une phase d'incertitude de ce
point de vue là c'est au moins 10
milliards
alors il fallait sans besoin d'un
canadair pour était un incendie le
président était un bon pilote de
canadair
mais l'impact budgétaire va être
considérable et ça nous place en
situation difficile en europe et ça nous
casse outre en situation difficile parce
que nous serons demain à la merci des
taux d'intérêt et c'est ce qui guette la
france donc il faut rester dans un cadre
budgétaire financer ces mesures qui sont
nécessaires et en même temps il y à des
mesures d'économies mais le vent
du temps chacun mesure la taxation des
gars fort ça prendra encore plus de
temps donc le gouvernement a devant une
équation budgétaire extrêmement
difficile
je souhaite qu'on reste dans les pures
des 10 milliards qu'on n'aille pas au
delà et nous attendons les propositions
du gouvernement avec le souhait que le
parlement puisse travailler dans un
délai raisonnable je pense qu'au point
où on en est il faut pas non plus se
précipiter parce que ce que nous allons
inscrire dans la loi ça va rester le
gouvernement table sur 3,4 pour cent
déficit avant économies budgétaires
qu'elle devrait d'après vous être la
part de ces économies et est-ce que vous
assumez dire qu'il faut dépasser en 2019
la barre des 3%
le temps de répondre à la crise je pense
que sur des économies on va aller
constater le sujet va être peut-être un
certain nombre de mesures qui étaient en
direction des entreprises dont on se
sent bien
quelles vont être dégradés ou repoussés
il n'y a pas beaucoup de solutions
aujourd'hui alors les 3%
on va les dépasser monsieur moscovici
qui a été entendu hier par la commission
des finances du sénat a admis que ça
pouvait ponctuellement à être le cas on
a un effet particulier cette année avec
0 9 point qui sont liées aux
transformations de la transformation du
cce en baisse de charge
donc c'est un élément complémentaire
mais la france va devoir se remettre
dans les clous ça veut dire que les
vraies difficultés elles sont en cours
d'exécution pour les prochaines je vois
pas comment on n'échappera un collectif
budgétaire assez tôt dans l'année
alors il ya la difficulté des chiffres
et la difficulté du calendrier jeudi au
sénat lors des questions au gouvernement
edouard philippe a précisé le calendrier
législatif des annonces du président les
mesures comment les faire adopter par le
parlement avant la fin de l'année et
bien ça devrait passer avant la fin de
la semaine prochaine explications jérôme
rabier emmanuel macron a décrété l'état
d'urgence économique et social pour
répondre à la crise des gilets jaunes et
le parlement est prié de se mettre au
diapason pour tenir ses promesses le
gouvernement a donc décidé de
bouleverser l'ordre du jour des textes
examiné la semaine prochaine dans les
assemblées l'objectif du gouvernement
est de proposer au conseil des ministres
un projet de loi qui viendra reprendre
l'ensemble des mesures annoncées par le
président de la république au conseil
des ministres donc de mercredi prochain
et l'idée est que ce projet puisse être
soumis à l'assemblée nationale puis au
sénat dans les meilleurs délais et être
adopté si les assemblées le souhaitent
avant la fin de la session ordinaire
présenté mercredi en conseil des
ministres le texte serait examiné jeudi
à l'assemblée nationale et vendredi au
sénat et ne comporterait que quelques
articles
cela permettrait d' acte et avant le 1er
janvier la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
l'exonération de la prime de noël est
l'exonération de la hausse de la csg
pour les retraités touchant moins de
2000 euros
concernant la csg il s'agit d'exonérer
de la hausse de l'année 2018 les
retraités qui prises individuellement ou
un revenu une retraite inférieure à 2000
euros net par mois
cela concerne trois millions sept cent
mille retraités et donc la moitié des
retraités qui ont vu leurs 16 g augmenté
en 2018 verront cette année cette
augmentation annulés au cours de l'année
2019 un rythme parlementaire fortement
accélérée qui constitue une exception
mais peu de risques que le texte soit
pour autant rejeter les oppositions de
droite comme de gauche au gouvernement
pouvant difficilement voté contre ces
mesures destinées à apaiser la situation
sociale du pays
vincent capo canellas nous avait déjà un
petit peu parlé de cette question du
calendrier pour vous est-ce qu'une
adoption avant la fin de la semaine
c'est un calendrier et nabeul et face à
cette accélération du calendrier est ce
que le parlement va pouvoir jouer
pleinement son rôle
le parlement entend bien je pense en
tout cas au sénat qu'il faut aller vite
pour délibérer sur ce nombre de mesures
qui ont été annoncées qui sont des
mesures d'urgence
mais je crois que le débat se limitera
pas à ça donc s'il ya des mesures
simples et si le parlement est associé
avant le dépôt du texte notamment le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances albéric de montgolfier
si les présidents des assemblées sont
associés si les prisons groupe sont
associés on pourra travailler vite et je
souhaite bien mais tous
ici quand même repousser le problème à
plus tard et je veux dire que avant le
printemps un collectif budgétaire sera
nécessaire parce qu'on voit bien qu'on a
repoussés les difficultés et que on joue
sur les déficits ça ne pourra pas durer
longtemps comme ça mais je vous propose
qu'on en vienne à notre dernier thème
l'attentât de strasbourg et les
questions qu'il n'a pas manqué de
soulever
[Musique]
c'est donc la ville de strasbourg qui a
été attaquée 14e attentat sur le sol
français depuis 2015 le parlement a
rendu hommage aux victimes minute de
silence dans les deux chambres
cette semaine à un moment d'union
nationale avant que ne revienne
le traditionnel ballet des questions
l'arsenal législatif actuel est il
suffisant comment cette attaque at elle
été possible alors que l'individu était
fiché s vincent capo-canellas cette
attaque relance comme beaucoup la
polémique sur ces fameux fichier s est
ce que c'est une polémique justifié
d'après vous je comprends qu'il y ait
des interrogations d'abord on a tous été
solidaires de nos voisins et nos amis
strasbourgeois et on a tous eu une
pensée dans les différentes assemblées
d'abord en direction des victimes
solidarité avec les strasbourgeois
et puis évidemment admiration pour les
forces de l'ordre qui ont résolu cette
affaire dans un délai qui a pu paraître
long mais qui quand on prend un petit
peu de recul montre quand même
l'efficacité du système
alors après il ya la polémique qui peut
revenir effectivement sur les fiches s
difficulté c'est que quand vous êtes
fichés s vous n'avez pas forcément
commis une infraction en soi vous est
peut-être commis d'infractions à
caractère pénal mais pas forcément une
infraction à caractère terroriste
et c'est toute la difficulté
législatives aujourd'hui faut-il revenir
sur ce point-là faut-il se donner un
élément juridique pour que le débat est
ouvert
et moi je souhaite pas aller dans
l'assurance surenchère jeu voir fleurir
des propositions soient des changes
nationalité autre je pense que ce sont
des faux débat d'abord on a des
institutions qui fonctionnent on a des
éléments avec les forces de l'ordre avec
les magistrats
et tout ça marche quand même pas si mal
que ça regardons avec eux magna précise
les améliorations qu'on peut apporter
mais pas de débat théologique au mauvais
moment prennent rapidement
coïncidence du calendrier le parlement
se pencher sur la réforme de la justice
cette semaine avec la création de ce
parc national antiterroriste ça ne
convainc pas le sénat ce parc est
pourquoi ça n'a pas convaincu le sénat
parce que jusque-là le parquet de paris
qui est chargé de l'antiterrorisme a su
trouver les moyens et amener fort bien
la politique judiciaire c'était le cas
de françois molins
ça sera le cas avec les miettes demain
donc voilà le débat reste en cours et la
réforme de la justice pour le moment
n'est pas encore dans une phase
totalement décisive
merci beaucoup merci vincent capo
canellas d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine merci thibault et on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
semaine d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]